you know my next guest i know you do she
has sold over
40 million albums worldwide her song the
boy
is mine is one of the biggest singles in
history now she's back with a new album
it's called b7 and it's out now here she
is brandy
hey kels hi i love you
i love you kelly clarkson oh my gosh
i literally was sitting here talking to
my friend at center and i was like
oh my gosh i used to jam like to your
records like
on the way to volleyball games out of my
walkman i'd be like sitting up
in my room pokemon i think that you are
so
great what an amazing career like not
only your heads but
other hits you've written for people
like as a writer you're just insane
but um how are you like how's the family
how's quarantine how's everything
it's been it's been crazy such a crazy
time you know but i i feel like my
family and i we we've been
you know a lot closer you know i've been
blessed to have my my parents here with
me my daughter so we've just been
uh spending a lot of quality time
together so your new
song baby mama first of all i love the
video i love this song but it's
dedicated to your daughter right so
it is it's dedicated to my daughter yeah
and she's excited about that and the
fact that you got a chance to wrap her
on it that's amazing
super super excited you know i had to
give my mommy my mommy points for that
you know just doing a song about her
about my unconditional love for her and
then just a
shout out to all the single moms out
there who have it you know tough you
know raising raising their families and
uh
and chance the rapper of being as though
he's such an amazing amazing talent and
yeah getting him on board was was was
was a great collaboration i'm i'm so
thankful that he got on board with that
oh my gosh yes it was great um so the
new album
is your first in eight years so i mean
first of all
took a minute um but like it was so what
does it mean to you to actually finally
get to release this do you feel like
you've been working on it for quite some
time just kind of evolving like how it's
gonna
end up sounding i i do i feel like this
is a very special album for me because
it's taking so long and because it's so
personal for me
um i got a chance to write a lot of the
songs on this album and just really take
my time to craft a body of work that i
can really be proud of
so i just i just hope the fans really
connect to it and relate to it
oh i'm sure i'm sure they will you have
i mean i'm just gonna keep doting on you
but you have
literally the coolest tone of
any singer like it's it's so incredible
it's the perfect amount of like pure but
like rotten like raspy
and and just soulful it's so good i just
and i remember
like when i was a kid i was so excited
because i loved you
i loved vinnie houston and y'all both
did cinderella
so i found out this story though that
you
way before this is this true that you
literally snuck backstage to meet her
before you were famous i definitely did
i was in the
nosebleed section of her concert and i
talked my way all the way backstage i
told everybody
all the ushers that i was going to pay
their bills because one day i was going
to be famous and they believed me
and i talked my way all the way
backstage but by the time i got back
there she was she was gone
oh that broke my heart but um i met her
later on and i got a chance
to do so many amazing things with her
and create a beautiful friendship
and i miss her to this day so yeah i
mean what an amazing thing too like i
can
i i'm with you in the sense of like
something that's just inspired me as a
vocalist
as well i also heard that miss diana
ross gave you some advice i love your
life by the way i like her
life is awesome so where it was it was
when you were coming up right that she
gave you some advice what was it yeah
she gave me a lot of cool advice number
one i was i was chewing gum a lot of the
time when we worked together and she
told me i need to
close my mouth when i'm chewing gum she
told me i need to make sure the powder
that i use on my face matched my neck
of course and then she also told me to
give everything that i do
100 you know she's such a beautiful
poised
classy you know timeless artist and you
know i always wanted to
you know follow in her footsteps in that
way just such a great example and
you know shout out to miss ross i love
her very much and just had the pleasure
of working with her
yeah she just like uh you know when you
think of like what the definition of
like a lady
like yes he is such a lady that's such a
grace
yeah i know i i love that i'm a big fan
of hers as well and her daughter
um but so so when are we finally going
to see a militia reboot okay we see all
these reboots and i was such a militia
fan
when is this happening you know what
it's it's we're still talking about it i
i'm so open for it i want it so badly
and i think just the way the show ended
it ended on a cliffhanger and i think
you know the people that have supported
militia over the years they they want
they want answers and
i feel like it it would be so
appropriate to do one and
and i just want everybody that's
watching i'm with it i
really want to do it so is is there a
a young singer actress you could see
starring in this like
taking on your part in moisha i don't
want to give my part up
i want to do the reboot i love it i love
it i don't know if you read
it different way you know people keep
rebooting in a different way they almost
take like a different role like somebody
else comes up i didn't know how y'all
would do that but
that's cool you're like me you like a
lot of jobs
i love i love to i love acting and i
would just i'd love to just tell that
story and see how far i could go
yeah well it is great to see you i'm i'm
literally i'm such a big fan i really
wish we could have done this in my real
studio because i want to do nothing but
give you a giant hug
and say thank you for the girl that
played volleyball like growing up
listening to all of your music and i
think that even now like i love baby
mama i love all
i love your texture i love your like
attack on a song i think
and i thought it was really interesting
and as a songwriter i really enjoyed um
just being inspired by you so thank you
so much you know what i feel the same
way about
you my daughter told you told me to tell
you that she loves you and just
we love you and um support you and
congratulations on your show and
everything that you're doing you're
you're such a such an inspiration kelly
honestly oh thank you so much
hey everybody brandi's latest album b7
is out right now you gotta go get it
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going